two three go hey what what okay good
since what remember you rehearsing to be
like hey I'm Tiffany Stephanie's like my
way hey I'm Christian and I'm Tiffany
Smith and on this week's episode of
movie threesome we have got the awesome
youtube music musician and foodie jimmy
wong and this tells me hey hey Jimmy
thank you for completing the movie
threesome here yes I wanted to ask you a
little bit about your YouTube channel
feast of fiction they mix the TV genre
the movie charminar the food from those
genres and they make it reality how did
that all come about well we're
brainstorming one that about shows that
didn't exist on YouTube that we thought
needed to exist and that was one of the
big ones cuz we grew up reading like
Harry Potter red wall and we're always
like oh my gosh the food they describe
is so amazing why isn't there like a
show that shows you how to make it we
met a couple years ago at Disneyland and
that was actually when you first met
Ashley you have to co-host on the show
she does like really beautiful culo
cupcakes and I was looking for something
to help me make a very specific cake and
I was like Ashley would you like to come
like co-host on the show for a day and
she came in and amelie became the
permanent host we talked about Harry
Potter there's so many different foods
in that movie specifically candies so we
brought in a treat Bertie Botts every
flavor beans that's what we have it is
so what we're gonna do is we're all
gonna take one all right let's give it
to the chef first all right cheers
cheers guys
Oh ah how it makes like candy sugar and
vegetables that I'm days disgusting oh
my god can smell yours from here mine
huh all right I'm a better day being at
the topic rotten weasel I'm throwing
with us get out what's this topic oh
these topics Tiffany Jimmy look there
are sports movies there are chick flicks
and there are food movies where food is
the theme so I figured let's get into a
discussion about food movies one of my
favorite ones of all time is shocked Ola
I like how you throw in the chocolate
off people's in queens is great you see
chocolate well I seen for me that always
stands out is hot shots it's the spoof
off for nine and a half weeks obviously
Charlie Sheen just nails that's so that
the egg strips and the bacon the pizza
it's just fun to see food take it to the
extreme this food can be equally
delectable and like you want to eat the
crap out of it it looks super gross and
unappealing Lake minority port when Tom
Cruise is daddy Mick blind and can't see
anything and decides to eat some food
and its just oh what's the one that
Bradley Cooper's doing the Bradley
Cooper's just about to a new movie out
called Bradley Cooper he ya burnt yes
there was the other one that just came
out that I really really liked where the
guy becomes a chef its effects macana
know where he lives right across the
street well cannibal journey that was a
really good 107 speaking of a
hundred-foot journey my mango just did a
food movie pole Fandango recently did a
pen dango foobie mm-hmm Fandango just
did a rita was of the people think which
one of these movies make your mouth
water the top four movies were chef 25%
julie and julia 23% ratatouille sixteen
percent and the hundred-foot journey at
eleven percent ratatouille is at the top
for me though because it looks so good
yeah animated they say to the computer
and they're like that cucumber is
imperfect John and he's like okay he'll
fix it boss and then
make it and it's perfect and you're
watching it like that's a perfect
looking cucumber have you guys made
ratatouille I'm please to fiction we
have it was delicious it's incredible
it's a very simple dish I mean the the
movie encapsulates wide such a beautiful
addition and it is the same thing in
real life oh that was a very sweet way
to describe ratatouille and right now as
we're sitting here talking about all
these food movies I feel a little bit
like I'm in a food coma so let's amp
things up a little bit with the weekly
oh yeah so just give you a little recap
we do the weekly wager here we bet on
the box office we put our butts on the
line every single week and we get
punished when we're wrong how do you
sell butts left that's when they pay us
by bus but the fans are the ones who
punish us they've been doing it every
week with the hashtag loser should I've
been keeping along last week you guys
were betting on the visit you gave an
estimate of 16.5 million you said 14.5
million actual estimated earning twenty
five point six million dollars which
means I two in a row two in a row what
do you know that's due in a row this
week's punishment comes from one of our
YouTube viewers Chris Lilly who says
loser should eat an entire jar of baby
food preferably some sort of vegetable
flavor there was actually something else
added in there that I forgot to read and
that is while making baby sounds what's
that in there yeah I am going to take my
punishment so bring in the baby food
this is wonderful soft look at this meal
for Queen orange is probably carrots or
something smells like SpaghettiOs baby
noises baby noises baby noises I feel
bad for babies I have never heard a baby
with such an extensive vocabulary this
week we're gonna bet on Maze Runner the
Scorch Trials I am going to say keep
eating the baby baby 41 million for that
film that's what I said 41 line yeah
maybe the baby needs help choo choo here
comes a health we baby food
take 343 one I alright so there we go I
say 41 the little baby says 43 speak
woman oh yeah I didn't realize that
Jimmy's making me Yuki open up baby this
week's loser should don't forget to use
the hashtag you guys it's like a jet
fighter what am I comment on your new
hand a driver sugar wasn't loose have to
do we're trying to make me hurt bad at
Berkeley baby baby food all over my
pants I will say a huge thank you to
Jimmy not only for completing our movie
threesome but also for 22 training the
baby food make sure you follow him on
social media at jf long yes and make
sure that you subscribe to our video
right there make sure you check out more
episodes right there download the
fandango movie clips app on your
smartphone and then check every week
right here for movie 3 so this one more
bite oh do it Jimmy Oh wasn't rolling a
great game that's tasteless